mais là tu termines en totu n'est pas
inquiet non pippa inquiète parce que je
pense que déjà comme l'a expliqué rachel
elle est très très bien entouré en plus
de ça on a appris qu'elle venait de
divorcer donc moi je pense que quand on
divorce on a envie d'être un peu au delà
de ça enfin on a envie un petit peu de
faire regretter son ex on a envie de
changement
d'accord on va dire donc toi t'as fait
ça paraît aussi que du change de mec qui
change de coiffure anges des mecs je
suis une bombe je me mets en blonde la
thermos de quoi que tu étais très belle
la tauromachie c'est en couple c'est la
seconde c'est la saint-valentin ouais
c'est donc c'est pas pareil à ce soir tu
fais quoi
j'attends je vois ce que mon chéri il
faut qu'on arrive à faire ça il va
tailler les vignes prépare une surprise
alors été ring diallo cadbury
c'est quoi
là il a vraiment faire c'est quoi je
vais demander qui t'a offert salma this
est dédié à marie c'est pas vrai bah oui
c'est du diamant idiote c'est magnifique
[Applaudissements]
et ça paie le mieux date
comment must at miche date très bien moi
j'ai quand même fasciné par dont
dépendent tous ces gens de télé réalité
on va en parler tout à l'heure ça brasse
abras des sceaux 4 700 milles ça je te
demanderai pas le cri parce que c'est
vulgaire mais ça coûte combien faut lui
demander à lui basile et je ne connais
pas ça se demande pas ça beau ce
ralliement environ environ
moi je te connais tu as vu comme tout le
monde est à capuchon google pour un prix
de ton cadeau enfin le prix du canot
n'est pas affichée mais pour revenir à
adel
[Rires]
justement quand tu divorces bat a besoin
d'un changement j'ai bien compris et
c'est plein de bon sens que dit non mais
absolument le sexe et amour c'est ta
nouvelle meilleure amie a tenté mais pas
un mot